outside the Supreme Court the anti
brexit demonstrators were in optimistic
mood inside the judges delivered their
devastating ruling with calm
deliberation an issue where the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson suspended
Parliament lawfully or simply to prevent
Parliament from holding his government
to account the effect on the
fundamentals of our democracy was
extreme no justification for taking
action with such an extreme effect has
been put before the court the court is
bound to conclude therefore that the
decision to advise Her Majesty to Perot
Parliament was unlawful because it had
the effect of frustrating or preventing
the ability of Parliament to carry out
its constitutional functions without
reasonable justification this case went
to the fundamental issue of the very
nature of democracy here in the United
Kingdom and it was a stress test if you
like of the separation of powers between
the three branches of government that is
conflict is far from over the outcome is
of vindication for Gina Millar the
campaigner who has fought the government
for the past three years to uphold the
law on brexit today is not a win for any
individual or cause it's a win for
parliamentary sovereignty the separation
of powers and the independence of our
British courts news of the court's
decision prompted a standing ovation
from delegates of the opposition Labour
Party conference where the party leader
was on his feet at the time the Supreme
Court has just announced its decision
and it shows that the Prime Minister has
acted wrongly in shutting down
Parliament as demand for Parliament to
be recalled gathered pace the Speaker of
the lower house stepped in I have
instructed the house authorities to
prepare not for the recall the
prorogation was unlawful and he's void
to prepare for the resumption of the
business of the House of Commons
Prime Minister Johnson received the news
in New York where he's attending the UN
General Assembly
he said he disagreed with the ruling but
would respect it the main thing is look
we're gonna get on and deliver brexit on
October 31st ooh yes of course
Parliament will not have to come back
but you know you'll respect that and get
on with back in London though his
position is now in question Parliament
will resume on Wednesday morning it
promises to be a tumultuous return Paul
Brennan al Jazeera the Supreme Court